we have one of the minus mighty
favorites here today with us texas paul
with his reacts he's he sent me
something this morning um a tweet from
beto o'rourke you know texas balls in
texas and he's down there trying to help
out beto well he's trying to help all
around the country he's been putting out
videos giving you an idea of exactly
what you can do to engage in your
democracy because you know here at the
tony michaels podcast we lean into
democracy we do not shy away from it we
will politicize every single goddamn
issue if we have to to save our
democracy i am not scared of that i am
not scared of what they call me like
charlie kirk is scared to be called a
fascist oh
poor guy
poor feller oh man he's so weak
we have someone who is not weak who is
who is just like me who loves who loves
to lean into democracy texas paul
welcome on tuesday texas ball how are
you
i'm wonderful man you got to forgive me
i sound a little bit like bullfrog today
had a little bit of a uh uh
covered rebound but i'm doing good oh
i'm doing is that is that from the um
the
the uh
the drug the same thing that biden had
is that is that is that what that is
just like the the second wave of it kind
of thing
yeah apparently this baa5 is pretty big
on doing rebounds whether you use the
pax love it or not you
you're you get over it and then it's
like your immune system has vietnam
flashbacks
oh i see that
i see so so it gives you just an extra
kick in the ass a few days later is that
what you're saying exactly i got you
well you sent me a tweet this morning
about uh beto and what's going on down
there and he he's really he's really
hammering through the state and i i i
heard that uh he had he had gotten sick
and everyone was lying about oh he's
suspended his campaign and he's quitting
and he's dying or something i don't know
some [ __ ] of course they're gonna lie
everything that that went through the
right wing
blind sphere like crazy immediately the
guy got a bacterial infection i mean you
can't do that many public appearances
without getting sick i mean he got
covered a few months back
and i mean
the guy literally if you've never been
to one of these town halls it's amazing
the amount of time that he puts into
these things he will literally if the
entire town hall stands up and says i
want a picture he will stay for the
whole thing and he puts his arm around
him he shakes their hands and you you
just can't come into contact with tens
of thousands of people and not catch a
buck every once in a while and that's
what happened here he got a bacterial
infection and uh you know he's been
burning the candle at both ends so he
got a little got a little sick he went
to the hospital they gave him uh an iv
um
he went home to rest for a few days and
then the right wing blogs
apparently he was
dying and his campaign was suspended and
everything no the campaign's running
running full bore
he just
well you know even even with him being
sick he's still kicking gray gab's ass
down there i mean that's that's the
craziest part you know he
he's he's running sick running sick but
he he can kick grades greg abbott's ass
um every which way
loose here and and i think i think
that's the the thing that betto has done
so well and i think it's a model for all
democrats everywhere now let me pull
this uh tweet up that you sent here let
me see if i can find it you sent it to
me this morning and he was trying to
point out exactly what was going on in
the state of texas uh i think that's
what he's saying right is he saying hey
we can fix this stuff now it's not hard
to fix texas here um i think that's what
he's saying he says uh
uh he tweets texas is number number one
in uninsured kids which is horrible
number one in uninsured residents which
is horrible number one in rural hospital
closures which is horrible and we're
talking about this is just how this is
just on health this list is just health
care this isn't other other problems
that like the power grid and stuff that
he's wanting to fix it's just health
care they're number 50 and access to
prenatal and um maternal care number 50
across an access to mental health care
and he's really been hitting the mental
health care thing a lot because we have
mental health care problems in this
country and we've seen it now with
some of these you know crazy
kooks um just absolutely barraging the
internet with crazy q and on conspiracy
theories i mean we need mental health
care in this country not just in the
state of texas but everywhere fast i
mean it is really uh affecting people
and this right-wing media has taken
advantage of these people who who
definitely have some um problems that
need to be helped with mental health
care they really need some mental health
care i mean it is crucial that we get
this to these people but i mean and he
really talks about that because i think
a lot of people are concerned about
mental health care coming out of the
pandemic i think a lot of people realize
how important mental health care is um
but he says at the bottom here we're
going to expand medicaid
bring 10 billion dollars a year back to
texas and help more people get the care
they need so here he is again and i've
i've said this before he has when he's
talking
when he does his speeches or when he's
when he's tweeting
um beto has a way of talking about
community and it's all about texas and i
think that's the thing that texas really
appreciates about him here other than
his opponent greg abbott who can't focus
on anything but
getting money from the nra and telling
women what the hell they can and can't
do with their bodies
yeah
i have to tell you that's one of the
things i absolutely love about beto is
that he's actually a genuine individual
and he approaches things you know a lot
of politicians are straight-up
sociopaths they are i mean it takes
this stuff hits you and it sticks with
you know that we cover a lot of heavy
stuff man and we're real people and it
can really get you down you know i mean
it can weigh on you after a while
and and
a lot of
it doesn't bother these people like
marco rubio or
marjorie taylor greene or lauren bobert
because they're freaking sociopaths that
don't nothing sticks to them but
you know beto really gives a [ __ ] so
when
you know like we talked about i think it
was last week or week before we were
talking about that [ __ ] application
that abbott sent in that he knew was
going to fail for medicare
and that hit beto o'rourke right in the
heart
because
i mean look at these statistics i mean
everybody thinks texas is rich because
we have oil we are not we are not the
income disparity is huge in texas and
these statistics are just horrifying
50th in access to prenatal and maternal
care
horrible yeah well not only not only
that they're limiting it just through
laws
for people to make their own choices in
that in that access that they do that
limited access that they do have which
is kind of pathetic but you know and in
that condition and in that state that
we're in now
we take our tax money and send it to the
federal government and we are we're a
net contributor we're not one of the red
states that is
you know uh
the wealth i call them the welfare red
states they're they're governors that
run their budgets off of the federal
government because they don't take in
enough taxes to pay their own bills let
alone chip in to help out we're actually
a net contributor
so instead of taking the matching funds
for medicare
back here where we desperately need it
that's what i was trying to point out
when we were having that discussion is
how desperately needed we we needed that
medicare and how cruel it was for abbott
to do that
i mean
well this is but this is the mo of the
republican party i mean for for years
and years and years after the aca which
most people know it as obamacare but the
affordable care act was was enacted um
the the mechanism to deliver states the
money for the aca
for medicaid and medicare but mostly
medicaid relief
inside those packages for the aca was
that the states had to adopt
those measures and a lot of republican
legislators said no we don't want your
money so basically
they were taking they were taking money
from the state giving it to the federal
government and the federal government
said hey we will give you this money
back plus some for your medicaid for
your citizens for your health care
mental health care prenatal i mean you
name it because it was medicaid funding
some medicare but mostly medicaid state
funding for folks who can't afford
health care and this and the republicans
in those states said ah [ __ ] you we
don't want your money our people don't
want your money and we definitely don't
want to give the people the money that
they deserve through this legislation
and really honestly a lot of voters went
along with it because they called it
obamacare they demonized it um i mean
hell they even they even got them to
vote for donald trump to actually cut
the goddamn thing which is crazy to
watch
this on this list about the rural
hospitals because they're number one in
rural hospital closures because the aca
one of the one of the things that it did
so well in the states that actually
adopted the medicaid expansion because
in rural areas i don't know if folks
know this but white people in rural
areas use more medicaid dollars than any
other demographic in this country and
and the reason why is because they're
they have such scarce area there's not a
lot of factories in those parts of the
country anymore there's not a lot of
jobs it's poverty stricken and they rely
on rural hospitals to get funding from
the government to keep it open so that
people in those areas have access to
health care so they voted against their
entire interest where the aca that was
the aca did a lot of things bad you know
it didn't do it well right but one thing
that the aca did really well where the
states expanded their medicaid is they
were able to keep a lot of their rural
hospitals open it was states like texas
missouri some other states that really
that really uh you know went the
opposite direction of medicaid expansion
where these rural hospitals were closed
and it affects those citizens in those
states but i think they're waking up to
texas but i think people are finally
seeing that hey there are people out
here who give a [ __ ] about us like beto
who want to talk about this stuff where
greg abbott wants to talk about how how
great it is that you got guns i mean
yeah when you when your kids got a 102
fever at two o'clock in the morning that
that ar-15 is not going to do [ __ ] for
you you're going to have to you know
this hit me personally we had a hospital
15 minutes up the road
in a little town called gilmer
it's shut down it's gone it's gone now
now if someone in that area
in my area
has an emergency
it's 30 minutes to the closest hospital
and then if you want to go to a real
level one trauma center if you've got a
real problem i mean
you know i mean you're talking about
there's some bad car wrecks out in rural
texas because it's not well lit and
and a lot of dwi's and stuff out here i
mean you get some bad car accidents
man you are 45 minutes away from the
first level one trauma center
and that's a recipe for death right
there because if you need a level one
trauma center
you have you need it now you know you
don't need it 45 minutes from now
yeah but texas paul but texas paul
there's woke people out there trying to
get these hospitals it's woke-ism right
it's the mother wokers out there i mean
this is really why it is so easy and i
don't i i think i think democrats are
doing a better better job every single
day really every single minute of
getting people in this country to
realize that when these people are
standing around talking about woke-ism
and woke [ __ ] and all this and and
worrying about people's genitalia and
who who they love and what books you're
going to read not going to read people
are going way to say it like we're
worried about damn hospital closing i'm
worried about not being able to get
access to my health care i want to make
sure the school has enough goddamn money
to operate to make sure that it's safe
from the governor that letting 18 year
olds go
use a credit card to buy up weapons to
murder 19 children like these things
these things actually affect these
people and if we just and i know it i
know it sounds you know everyone thinks
it's gross but i say it here i don't
care we have to politicize these issues
we have to lean into democracy and i
really think that o'rourke and well and
even john fetterman is doing a great job
in pennsylvania of of this brand of
leaning into democracy leaning into it
not leaning away from it not running
from the the woke and all that crap um
just completely leaning into it i mean
really honestly paul if you think it's
do you think it's woke and i don't know
really what what they're talking about
anymore but do you think it's woke to
want a hospital in your rural area do
you think that's woke i don't know
absolutely i do
absolutely i do because i happen to know
what the definition of woke is and yeah
i'm completely aware we really need
right
our hospital wasn't it was like a if i
remember correctly it was a level four
center it wasn't it wasn't it was not
for
severe horrible you know okay we got
somebody coming in with a missing arm
that's not what they did there but you
know
if you had if you needed stitches or you
had a broken arm or you had a
sick kid with a fever or something like
that it was right there and it really
helped
these
trauma centers that were dealing with
these horrible issues well now they're
dealing with all of them and beto is
just i'm so proud of him i am so proud
of him he has just been textbook in
exactly what you're talking about
he takes these people that come in to
heckle him and cause problems at his
rallies and he says okay
tell me what you think he doesn't just
let him sit there and and and jerks
about it talk to me talk to me tell me
what you think and then i'll tell you
where i'm at and they're like oh
wow
okay
right why you're what what's this guy
right one of the greatest videos is
there was there was a trump supporter
she shows up at the rally she has a
manga hat on and and i believe she's
asking him i don't remember exactly what
issue but he talked to her in the crowd
in the and he's not even on rallies
they're like community halls right like
it's not even like this big huge arena
that he's just that he's just putting on
a comedy show like like trump does right
he's actually going and talking to
people and and of course these p these
places are crowded and the overflows are
full because they're really small that's
the intention because he wants to talk
to people but this one where she's
wearing a manga hat and by the end she
comes up to him to take a picture and he
signs he signs the bill of her of her
maga hat which is and then she puts it
on which is incredible which is it just
it just goes to show and i i've tried to
say this for for as long as we've been
on the air which uh we're at episode
216 or something like that i've been
trying to say it over and over and over
again that look it's not about really
what you say it's how you say it and and
a lot of times if you're saying
something the way that people want to
hear it that is important because then
you can deliver the message that people
need to hear as opposed to this queuing
on garbage and all this nonsense about
about oh we're butt hurt because people
are calling us fascists because we are i
want to bring in
our our our executive producer and
co-host gabe sanchez gabe how are you
this morning uh not butthurt
not butthurt for being called the
fascist
oh come on
uh
yeah i mean well no i think yeah you're
right you got to call them out every
single day every every type of bull
don't do not give them an inch because
they will take a mile
oh yeah well and that's that's what we
try to do here two hours every single
day is to is to call them out call out
their [ __ ] politicize every single
issue if we can and give you the ammo
that you need to go out and talk about
this stuff
because that o'rourke is actually going
to set policy so he has to go out and he
has to actually communicate to the
communities about the community policy
that he wants to set if they were to
elect him right but here on this show
we've got to do it on a national
spectrum we've gotta we've gotta do
these things and to watch oh my god to
watch charlie kirk cry
on fox news texas paul to watch him cry
on fox news when when joe biden didn't
even call him a nazi because that's what
i would call charlie kirk to his face if
i was if i if i was within spinning
distance of charlie kirk i totally would
call him a nazi but
joe biden calls maga republicans
semi-fascist and he's just he's offended
he's a completely offended it was it's
it's a sight to see i'm gonna show it
here but what's your thoughts on these
people now being
butthurt about being called names i
guess because they're
they're they're weak well you know i
want to expand on what gabe just said
right there he just nailed it you know
we we have
for so long this this this was the
problem and this is what i talk to my
people about all the time that watch my
videos and follow my shows is that for
the longest time we
when they go low we go high
and that's [ __ ] that is [ __ ]
we have to
we have to slug it out we allowed
ourselves to say okay we'll run on our
ideas and we allowed the other side to
have this culture war
and we didn't want to get down into it
well we have to and like you say every
day we have to politicize it every day
we have to swing at these people we have
to call them what they are don't be
polite about it and say well there are
definitely some republicans we can work
with no no you're you're [ __ ] fascist
that's what you are
you're [ __ ] fascist and the ones that
aren't calling fat the fascists out well
you're you're you're fascist also
because you're allowing it to happen
you know and if charlie kirk wants to be
butthurt about this and have a tantrum
bring it you want to throw rocks when
you live in a glass house come on man
this is a conversation i want to have
well i think you're right i think
charlie
and gabe i know you have some feelings
on this but i think charlie here um he
he really did not do himself a favor by
whining and crying let's take a look at
this um
um on fox news i'm not sure which trader
tv show this is it looks like someone's
filling in for laura ingraham the the of
the the uh the
born and raised nazi apparently but uh
of course
they have the ghoul stephen miller on
here on this on this panel to to defend
that they're not fascist here's stephen
miller is he's the one designed and him
and charlie kirk are designed to defend
that they're not fascist who is this guy
in the middle does anyone know this guy
is that uh that is frightened yeah you
talking about kirk i think i'm not sure
yeah
that he's in between uh too fascist and
he's about to try to uh justify a way
that he's not a fascist yeah but charlie
i'm blanking on his name but he is a
right wing of course he is yeah he goes
the fascist yeah i mean he he does he
does go after people from the
kind of funny vile things but yeah he
looks paranoid for sure is it kind of
funny how they're like you know what
we're gonna get we're gonna get people
to come on here and defend our or be
back against the word fascist who should
we have on well who's the most fascist
we can find they're like oh well let's
bring those people on here is um here is
human plate face uh charlie kirk um
talking about how he's really upset and
you know what i'm rubber you're glued
nana boo boo
sticks to you let's listen you have to
remain peaceful on our side but i do
think that if they're gonna escalate the
language then game on like okay if
you're going to call us a bunch of
fascists we're not going to take that
anymore you're the fascist joe biden and
there's other words we could use as well
we're not going to be like well oh he
would use the word nazi oh my god is
that what he's saying because that's
what he's saying right yeah i think well
i think what he's describing is you know
self-fulfilling prophecy right he's like
if you call us this
then we will
we will double down on the thing that
you you claim that we are we will be the
bad guys it's like one of those people
it's like
when somebody gets called out and like
oh that's what you guys want us to be
then we'll just do it we'll just do it
right and they'll use that as an excuse
to be like well you guys want us to do
it it's like no you wanted to do it we
called you out
and you said well cat's out of the bag
now and that's what's happening here so
he's like oh we could call him very bad
words much worse than fascists we could
do this we could do that it's like yeah
we know because you guys are these
things they already do want to do them
you're just looking for an excuse to
make it okay and acceptable
um oh and the guy in the middle is uh is
kurt
schlinker oh he's a he's a faker
sprinter curt sphincter he's a well he's
a total he's a total dick bag he uh he
goes and he attacks people he's
right-wing he's
irrelevant in many ways he looks like a
bag of dicks i'm just saying look at him
he's he's really he's not like i mean
that's a great that's a great snapshot
that you have right there that you
haven't stopped right
with this with this now texas paul
what's funny about this little tantrum
that charlie's having here is that there
was an event called cpac down in your
state uh just just i think was under a
month ago and they actually had up on
the screen it said we are all domestic
terrorists like what the [ __ ] are you
kidding me and your butt hurt that that
that joe biden's calling you a
semi-fascist when you're
self-proclaiming that you people are
domestic terrorists give me a [ __ ]
break
yeah
that was hilarious i mean you've got to
have a picture of that banner if you're
going to bring that up that was just
this was not faked folks i mean they
really across the main banner above
their stage was
we are domestic terrorists
they were so proud of what they said out
loud they said it out loud too
constantly during the entire cpac they
constantly leaned into the fact that
yeah we're domestic terrorists we we
were there on on january 6th um i i
guess it's not blm and antifa anymore i
guess they're proud of it now but yeah
well that was hilarious talking about
the
the biggest cell phone of the century
yeah let me
right i mean it's you know it's non-stop
every day whether it's the you know the
the trump mar-a-lago search from the fbi
and then making all these excuses and
continuously getting owned it's them
admitting that they're domestic
terrorists you know or is them
you know like charlie kirk admitting
that they're fascist or or at least
admitting by accepting the role that
they've been assigned by society it's
like no one no one assigned this role to
you you actively chose right to be this
[ __ ] human being
and we're just shedding light on it well
i also want to point out that at charlie
kirk's little turning point usa student
thing where he invited the the the uh
accused pedophile matt gatz to come and
and frolic with the students there were
there were actual nazis outside
like with flags in support of charlie
and his organization they weren't there
to protest him they were there because
they enjoyed turning points into this
band they love it down there i mean do
you all remember charlottesville i mean
everybody remember oh yeah right okay
there was a group there that at the time
called themselves identity europa they
were one of the big
sponsors of that now they call
themselves the american identity
movement these groups keep rebranding
i mean vanguard is the same way they
rebranded it became patriot front which
i gotta agree this group this group got
hacked
and their internal communications
uh one of them that just stuck with me
was
infiltrating the gop is broke
infiltrating turning point usa is woke
they have decided instead of going to
the barrel they're going to go to the
tree
and they are they are sending people
into these organizations like turning
point usa
to recruit
they are i mean they said it themselves
that they're doing that now turning
point usa avidly denies this but then
you have people like crystal clanton
that was working there and i don't know
if you anything about that scandal but
that one goes all the way to clarence
thomas he's still that today have you
heard about that that that no i think
you sent me an article on that this
morning i haven't i haven't had a chance
oh my goodness she got okay she she had
text messages where she said i hate
black people
she got caught they fired her okay
you're talking about it she worked for
turning points usa she was a staffer or
something she was
right they bragged about her like crazy
she was a higher level
executive at
turning point usa she gets fired
jenny thomas loves this girl
loves her so much she moved her into her
house and hired her after she gets fired
from turning point usa for saying i hate
black people wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait
yeah this this does sound very familiar
yeah you're saying a turning point usa
staffer who is caught texting she hates
black people goes and lives in jeannie
thomas's house the wife of clarence
thomas right four years okay okay well
i'm
this is what's coming out they found
letters
because now get this you'll never
believe where chris crystal clanton is
now
she is
a clerk for federal judge william pryor
oh i'm sure it's i'm sure it's not a
trump appointed judge i'm sure that's
not the case it gets better though it
keeps getting better people were like
how did this woman end up clerking for a
federal judge well they found letters
from clarence thomas that of course
recommended her to go to law school
um and and and helped her get into law
school and then they found letters
helping her get the job with william
pryor and now it's a big stink's coming
out because people are like why the hell
are you hiring this woman for such a
prison a federal
judge clerkship is prestigious it's a
stepping stone to a
and this is where it gets really bad
it's a stepping stone to a
supreme court clerkship
in the letters that they found from
thomas
he says
he's grooming her to be his clerk
i mean if you cannot make
grooming
yes grooming her to be his clerk if she
does well in her job for william pryor
he's going to hire her for a clerk he's
going to give her a clerkship in the
supreme court
here is i think
uh
crystal clinton um clarence thomas's
wife's assistant apparently it's or her
assistant is that right served as
turning points usa candace
this is back and
this is back in 2019 so this is stuff
like people have been talking about this
for a little bit now um
so i just wanted to give context put a
kind of a face to the name that we're
talking about right now but here's
apparently the quote from the text
message she sent she said i hate black
people like [ __ ] them all i hate black's
end of story is what the quote is here
now again i don't know but this is a
picture
of
her with
jeannie thomas and with clarence thomas
here
which is yeah holding a bottle of wine
it looks you know it looks kind of weird
that's their house by the way that's
that's their virginia home oh she lives
there she lived there for a year so this
is the home where she had resided with
them i guess
yeah and
what gets even better where this circles
back to charlie kirk and what we're
talking about is see when charlie kirk
fired her
he's like i don't want to talk about
this we don't have a nazi problem at
turning point usa see we took decisive
action that was his quote we took
decisive action within 72 hours and we
fired this person well now that
he found out that clarence thomas loves
her
and is
protecting her and grooming her he
doesn't want to be in conflict with the
supreme court justice so now
charlie kirk has come up with a
ridiculous story that when he said that
and this is recent this is this is not
2019 stuff this is recent he has
completely changed his story that that
statement that i took decisive action
and fired
this person within 72 hours well i
wasn't talking about crystal clanton
i was because she was set up there was a
rogue employee that we haven't heard
anything about we don't know who this
rogue employee supposedly is that hacked
her they hacked her and they it's all
terrible
that's who i was taking decisive action
about because i fired that employee
within 72 hours i didn't mean crystal
clamp yeah of course you let that sit
out there since 2019. and not said a
word but now that you know
she's
i don't even know the white man put it
clarence thomas's pet or whatever
now charlie curt
is totally backstepping and oh yeah
crystal clanton's great she never did
anything she loves
her right then why did you fire her and
that'll be the next thing that changes
is we didn't fire her she just took a an
opportunity to work with jenny thomas or
something like that right well you know
this is the same story across the board
with these right-wingers um we we talked
to dakota adams and tasha adams who who
are the estranged wife and a strange son
of stuart rhodes the founder of the oath
keepers and they even described us in
our first interview like how the oath
keepers got started and what stewart
tried to do to keep the the fascist the
white supremacists out of his group
because he understood one thing about
paramilitary groups is they eventually
become infiltrated and taken over by
white supremacists and he tried his
damndest like for years and years and
years stewart rhodes believe it or not
tried his damnedest to keep racist and
white supremacist and neo-nazis out of
his paramilitary group the oath keepers
but it's inevitable like there's nothing
you can do when you when you spread
right-wing fascism no matter how
little or how much when when you're
doing these things you're only inviting
those people to take over your groups
and turning points usa is no different
than the oath keepers um a cpac is no
different than the proud boys i mean it
literally these white supremacists these
terrorists they take over these groups
they infiltrate them and they become
part of their power and the reason why
they become part of their power is
because of the recruitment like you were
saying texas paul because that's one
reason why stewart rhodes was led down
this road after donald trump was elected
because it became so easy to elect
people on fear and hatred and bigotry it
was so easy that they actually became
the terrorists themselves and now they
declare themselves here's a video from
that cpac event that we were talking
about earlier this is [ __ ] real this
is not made up watch they did this
themselves this is legitimate right and
then this is the video of it listen to
the announcement here
ladies and gentlemen we are all domestic
terrorists
please welcome founder of this
that now i wanna i wanna i want you to
hear it again but but listen there is
there is a woman in front of a
microphone who is reading a script to
announce these people can you imagine
when she gets the script of we are all
domestic terrorists she's like wait what
would you want me to read this out loud
into the damn microphone
i can't even she's like we gotta we got
a last minute change in the script she's
like okay all right i mean
now we'll be praying for what the [ __ ]
but she also says it so
calmly right what she i mean she did not
she did it professional
now i don't know who this announcer is
but boy did she have to really uh look
deep inside let's let's listen to it one
more time ladies and gentlemen we are
all domestic terrorists
please welcome and there's like i don't
know a couple you know there's tens of
people in this room not photoshopped
people that's real that is not that's
what's
real that is like we're being
tongue-in-cheek it's like why would you
why would you even wanna
like
cross that line like if you want to be
tongue-in-cheek about other things
okay sure but when you're talking about
something like this like we are we're
you are
you are giving a line that is you know
admitting to being domestic terrorists
and what they say oh it was a joke we
were being you know coy with it or what
it's like
there's a big difference between
saying what you said
and making a joke of it right like
especially when these are people who 100
percent believe
to the millionth degree that everything
that comes out of any of their mouths
from the republican party is truth
they they're the same people who believe
what comes out of tucker carlson's mouth
from his entertainment show they're the
same people who believe what come out of
trump's mouth which is like when people
like oh he was being sarcastic you know
when people are trying to defend his
racism or defend his his bigoted remarks
or whatever it might be the immediate
response from the right is oh you guys
you guys i obviously don't understand
comedy you don't understand sarcasm he
was being slight with his words like
yeah okay
you know i don't know what you remember
is you remember
this cpac was in 2020 or i think it was
in 2020 or 2021 where they had the the
the nazi symbol as the stage like that
was 2021 because it was it was
there were two events that happened it
was one after another there was one in
2020 and i'm blanking on what it was
and then 2021 happened
and it was the uh they're not home let
me let me look up what happened to 2020
because there was another one that was
like nazi related but but this is
gorban who is a self-professed white
supremacist i mean right victor orban
the the the
head of of uh hungary the the president
of hungary
yeah prime minister hungary pardoned me
um is a self-professed white supremacist
he he doesn't make any bones about it
and he was keynote speaker at cpac last
year i mean or this this yeah well this
one that that's the one that they were
here in dallas yeah yeah
which is which is uh even more crazy
that they had a real-life fascist
dictator from from europe come over here
and speak at their domestic terrorist uh
rally which is kind of crazy it's it
well i mean it's not kind of crazy it's
it's par for the course and that's why
that's why when you see charlie kirk
whining and crying about jill biden
calling him and semi-fascists you should
kind of laugh because they've done this
to themselves right paul i mean they've
done this to themselves
absolutely and you know
when we talk about charlie kirk throwing
stones
well
let's do this
your group
has been
absolutely following putin's playbook
100
they've taken their young volunteers and
people you need to know this if your
kids are in college and high school and
there's a turning point usa
uh
uh chapter there uh they are all over
the country they're literally thousands
upon thousands of these chapters now all
over they've they made a point of
getting into every college campus every
junior college campus everywhere they
are using your kids
to do the same thing that putin did with
his troll farms they're using them they
they give them a social media
script
and they have them go out into social
media and spread misinformation
disinformation and pro
fascist pro-gop [ __ ] all over the
internet they are using these kids as a
troll farm
and it's it's disgusting they're really
doing this well turning points usa is
not only not only are they well
organized they're well funded if you go
um because we've had ben glebe on the
show and we've had rachel bittikoffer
who have both
you know rachel's a great friend of the
show and ben now too but um they both
have debated charlie kirk on his debate
night that he has at his at his turning
points usa in phoenix and when and when
uh when you go to his complex in phoenix
it's like a [ __ ] three-story building
this isn't like some kind of shanty out
in the middle of nowhere this [ __ ]
place is like three stories and it's
fully staffed they have hundreds of
people on that staff that is designed
and organized to spread fascism all
around the country and that is why
charlie kirk is actually offended when
joe biden calls him a fascist because
he's like whoa
people are on to me and that's the bad
that's that's where they draw the line
is not that they're not fascist or not
that they're not right-wing or nazis
it's i don't want you to know that i am
right because they've always thin veiled
this fascism for years and decades and
decades with conservatism and that's
that nonsense that is starting to break
through and people are starting to see
these [ __ ] for who they are you're not
conservative you're not [ __ ] because
you're farthest away from a reagan
type conservative that there is you are
a god damn maga america first nazi that
is exactly what you are when you're you
know rubbing elbows with the likes of
nick fuentes marjorie taylor green and
some of these others
well you know
if you don't mind me going back to your
comment about homer rhodes um
he tried very hard to keep the out nazis
out of his group but his group was
actually founded in racism
the oath keeper started down here in
texas on the border
that's that's what they started as is
they were going to be a private militia
to patrol the border
and
so they tried desperately to keep
anybody with
direct ties you know somebody that like
the southern poverty law center could
identify
from being part of the organization but
they themselves were just flagrant
racist oh wow these people weren't going
down and standing in 100 plus degree
heat and let me tell you south texas is
a desert it is the mexico badlands okay
it's it's the sonoran desert these these
fat asses were not going down there and
standing in 100 520 110 degree heat
because they they were afraid you know
because they had a legitimate beef
what drove that was racism
and that's and that's what stewart
rhodes was trying to cap was not that
racist was in his group he just didn't
want people publicly being racist they
had they had people they had people they
told us his family told us that during
during his rise as as the oath keepers
spread across the country because they
were opening chapter here and chapter
there in chapter here and the way that
they kind of did this was they did it
with uh you know veterans and and law
enforcement right that's that was kind
of their aim as opposed to paramilitary
groups
they want misfits they really don't want
institution they don't want
institutional people they want misfits
so when oath keepers took a different
direction but they were having a lot of
trouble keeping outright racist out of
their group and what i mean is is they
would have social media people that
all they did was scour their members
social media and to if they even hinted
at racism on their social media because
they didn't want to be accused of it
right and this is again this is what
we're talking about with charlie kirk is
they want to implement these policies
they want to be bigots they want to be
right-wing fascists they want to tell
women what they can and can't do they
want to take away people's vote people's
rights but they don't want anyone to
know that they're nazis right just like
you know why that is do you you know why
that is
because your average republican
middle-aged white guy that looks like me
is a racist usually right they usually
are i i'm and i'm not scared to say it
republicans
i would probably guess 90 of them are
racist they'll tell you they aren't
and that's where that line splits
he can get money out of these people for
doing racist things like they were doing
down at the border
you know because then they can call it
well oh border security this happened
the other but the minute that you have
actual nazis in your organization
that are out
then these people that are racist
they're like okay that's too far
right i don't want to be known he's
gonna find me as a racist i don't want
to be known as a racist well that's why
charlie
that's why charlie and the turning
points usa people were so terrified and
the event organizers were terrified at
that event in florida when the let's go
brandon desantis nazis showed up because
they were desantis nazis i mean we know
in florida there are outright neo-nazis
that support ron desantis and they love
ron desantis and ron desantis will not
speak against them at all and the reason
why
right well i mean he wants to ignore
that they even exist but they definitely
exist right and i think and i think
that's the point here is that charlie
kirk again just like stewart rhodes are
just like rhonda santos they're not butt
hurt that someone's calling them a
fascist they just don't want their their
donor block to believe it because if
they believe it they might get peeled
off they might lose
a bit of that and i want to i want to
make something clear i you know i would
i will admit that not you know this is
like a square rectangle kind of theory
here right like from if everyone
remembers geometry not
all republicans are fascist or racist
but all fascist and racist are
republicans republicans right so like
let's keep like i'm i don't i don't know
not the word group or whatever but like
even the fact that some of these people
like charlie kirk and others
were like uh you know offended at the
fact that it wasn't full-on racist right
it was or full-on fascist it was
semi-fascist right they they hated the
idea of any i mean which should be the
normal response of anyone like oh whoa
[ __ ] no i'm not a fascist
charlie's response was and all these
other people are going to be like
uh it's not that we're not fascist it's
if you want us to be a fascist we'll do
we'll be a fascist out in the open
because you want us you need a you need
a boogie man you need a monster it's
like no you were already those things we
just [ __ ] turned the room light on
and showed everyone who you really were
and what your true colors were
um so they will use that as an excuse
and you'll see that be like well they
they want us to be this thing let's
let's let's really be that thing
and here's a piece of tape from uh
from charlie kirk's uh older brother the
bowtie rube tucker carlson from white
privilege tonight um let's listen to
what they have to say here on tucker's
show this is back in march about fascism
the right is going to pick a fascist
within 10 to 20 years because they're
not going to be and what turned out to
be one of the most chilling statements
ever made i mean that is that is
chilling when they say yeah the right
within 10 or 20 years but he didn't even
he just agreed with it he didn't be like
oh that's that's bad for the party we
shouldn't have that like that that that
is something that we should totally you
know disavow and make sure that we don't
have within the republican party he goes
yeah yeah that'll probably happen well
but i mean the thing is is that like
like you made the point earlier texas
paul
people like like uh tucker carlson hail
vladimir putin which is really gross i'm
gonna show some of that video in the
shitless round up here but he also he
also loves victor orban i mean he went
over to hungary and gave him fellatio
pretty much for his tv show to to the to
the hungarian fascist the hungarian
hitler that is
orban yeah that that interview was
disgusting
that if you saw the one where he
actually sat down with orban
that was disgusting i mean this man is a
i mean he is brutal he is brutal yeah
not only does he not only is he a racist
but he hates the lgbtq community i mean
he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah they they they
kill gay people in hungary they do
i mean this is
no joke about it they say well we're
going to send them to prison but they
always end up at this
they end up dead and right well they're
they're barreling down this same kind of
road here in this in this country when
when they when they're talking about
ostracizing uh people who identify as
certain things like leave people to [ __ ]
alone would you please and i think
that's the most important part and i
want to end here because we're gonna
have to go to a break and go to the
shitless roundup is texas paul tell us
tell the people out there because you
know we talk about it here is leaning
into democracy because
lindsey graham talks about riots but i
actually don't think that's how they're
going to try to take over this country
they're going to do it inside our
government so we shouldn't worry so much
about violence in the streets we should
worry about these fascists in our
government so tell them how to lean into
democracy and give them an idea what
they can do to really save our democracy
well look folks this is really simple
this is really simple the ballot box
right now today still matters
if we don't show up and vote
next election it won't
it won't if you give republicans power
our democracy goes down the toilet so
do these things
volunteer save democratic candidates
money
save their money from having to pay
people to do things phone bank for them
you can phone bank nationwide on a cell
phone with no long distance fees
whatsoever
knock on doors for a candidate
find money
i mean find it anywhere you can and send
it i don't like money in politics you
don't like money in politics but the ads
are not free and this is how the game
works now so we have to fight the way
the rules are set now
so fun the hell out of your your
democratic candidates ones that you like
nationwide and your local candidates the
house races and
right now we're coming coming up against
the deadline in a lot of states
for registration
in the state of texas they've been
kicking people off the voter rolls so
you have to check your registration now
so that you have time to fix it if
they've screwed with you
because it's an entire process to get
these things get yourself back on the
voter registration rules
your state will have
a a website that you can go to
there's a there's a dot gov
website here in texas you can go to to
check your registration i'm sorry i
don't have it memorized but it it's the
first one that pops up when you google
it
check your registration and more than
anything
if you have to crawl over
burning broken glass to vote
if you have to lose your job to take the
day off to vote
whatever it takes our country's in
danger folks you have to vote and you
had to vote democrat the entire ticket
up and down we have to end the
republican party
because they are openly
embracing fascism they are openly
telling you
we are going to do this we are going to
be a fascist government because we want
to be a christo-fascist white
nationalist government
period
they're not hiding it it is what they
are telling you they're going to do it's
not just me telling you we show you
every week
tony michaels puts on one of the
greatest podcasts there is out there
because he and gabe sit there and they
show you these people out of their
mouths
every
damn
day
what these people say
and they're telling you and like maya
angelou said when somebody tells you who
they are
believe them
we have to vote it's the most important
thing you're going to do in your life
this year
so everybody go out get registered to
vote check your registration check your
family your friends registration make
sure they know to check their
registration if they're not registered
find them a way to get registered
registered in the vote phone bank give
money whatever you can do to lean into
your democracy and engage in your ballot
because your way of life depends on it
texas paul it's tuesday thanks for
joining us buddy i love having you here
on tuesday
everyone go follow texas paul go to the
midas touch network channel as well
you'll see all texas paul's reacts there
as well he's a midas mighty favorite
texas paul my friend
it said it's been great to talk to you
i'll i'll talk to you later on i'm sure
in in the dm's in private so
absolutely and mad take two seconds to
make a plug absolutely go ahead sir
go to texaspalmers.com and buy a shirt
or a mug
i'm going to shamelessly push my
merchandise because i'm telling you
i take a very small portion of that and
a big portion of it goes to pay for
those great ads that might as touch as
putting out and this last two months
i hate to keep going back to money folks
but
money is huge they just poured 20
republicans just poured 20
million dollars into florida because val
dimmings is kicking the [ __ ] out of
marco rubio and desantis is in trouble
with charlie crist charlie crist came
out swinging please folks
buy the merchandise i know
everybody hates money in politics but
god dock it man it is it is the weapon
we have besides our vote it is
well go love you don't
go to texas paul was at texas paul
merch.com is that what it is paul
merch.com
texaspaulmerch.com go follow texas paul
and all the the socials the tweety
tweets the tiki talks and the
instagrammies go follow them there
american made union american made
products only
well texaspaul merch.com texas paul
thank you we'll see you next tuesday my
friend everyone stick around we'll be
right back right after this break